[Music]
more talk tonight about the oakland days
and a move
out of the east bay perhaps to las vegas
ron futrell is in the newsroom with the
latest a-ron
kirsten tuesday is the day the oakland
city council
will vote on a proposal that they hope
would keep the
team in oakland now we've got a sneak
peek at that proposal today
the mayor of oakland libby shaft she
loves it the oakland a's
do not this is what the proposed 12
billion dollar project
would look like in the east bay a new
baseball stadium is just part of it the
oakland a's president dave cavell who
has been to las vegas many times now
looking for a new location here in town
for a new ballpark says today's planned
release
by oakland would not work for the a's he
says quote
we're really far apart in quote now one
of the major sticking points on the
project
the mayor wants the a's to pay 400
million dollars for affordable housing
units in the city
and the a's say the regulations in
california
make it very tough for them to work with
and they don't have those same
regulations here of course
in nevada recently minority owner of the
ace billy bean visited las vegas
ballpark and he really liked what he saw
i got to be honest with you the
facilities here are better than we have
in oakland i mean you know i mean it's
no secret
you know we're trying to secure a new
stadium we have an old stadium but the
facilities here i mean
when our guys get sent down to triple a
they're actually going up in terms of
the you know the playing and the stadium
and so it
it's really an amazing amazing place
okay we agree the a's played an
exhibition game at las vegas ballpark
couple years ago
it's possible they could play there
while a new stadium is being built
in las vegas the a's have looked at 20
potential sites here in town the key
here
and this is the key of course there is
still no word who would pay
the one billion dollars it would take to
build a retractable dome
stadium here in las vegas cavall says he
is planning another trip
to vegas next week following the tuesday
vote by the city
but again the news today the a say the
proposal
the proposed that was released today is
one that they would not accept
next week we could see the a's ramp up
their efforts for a new home here
i'm ron futrell 8 news now